es spricht wirklich immer mehr dafür
dass uns eine alien sonde besucht hat
das objekt obama war schon ziemlich
seltsam aber weitere untersuchungen
legen tatsächlich sehr nahe dass es sich
nicht um ein natürliches sondern ein
künstliches objekt gehandelt haben muss
sprich eine alien sonder eine von
außerirdischen ausgesendet das
raumfahrzeug das ist nicht ganz
unwahrscheinlich dass dieses datum in
die geschichtsbücher eingehen wird wie
das forschungsteam auf die idee kam die
hintergründe jetzt wirklich zum science
fiction
hier gibt es täglich mega spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal denn
nur dann verpasst er kein video herzlich
willkommen so haben sich wissenschaftler
und wissenschaftlerinnen obama bisher
vorgestellt ein ganz langer stein
allein das war schon sehr seltsam und es
scheint auch nicht so zu sein um am ohr
oder 1 das erste interstellare objekt
ist wahrscheinlich eine alien sondern
wir hatten ja mit als erster darüber
berichten die medien sind extrem
vorsichtig und nur wenige melden diese
nachricht das ist auch verständlich denn
es klingt schon extrem verrückt eine
alien sonde soll uns besucht haben aber
sogar die renommierte zeitschrift
spektrum die wissenschaftszeitschrift
hat inzwischen darüber online berichtet
und das will schon etwas heißen es ist
eben auch nicht irgendein forschungsteam
sondern mit dabei ist apple professor
für astrophysik an der harvard
university direktor des instituts für
siri computation am harvard smithsonian
center for astrophysics und vorsitzender
des fachbereichs astronomie der harvard
university und dr
die alias stipendiat am institute for
sea and computational design team vom
fach und dazu mit einem absolut
renommierte astrophysiker an der spitze
wollen er ist zudem vorsitzender des
beratungsausschusses des breakthrough
star show projektes initiiert von
stephen hawking und julia dem russischen
milliardär ist das ein projekt bei dem
dutzende mini raumschiff an riesigen
sonnensegeln richtung alpha centauri
geschickt werden
miller hat es mit 100 millionen dollar
finanziert ein laser soll seinen impuls
auf ein nur wenig gramm schwere
sonnensegel geben
er schießt von der erde aus und
beschleunigt die mini sondern auf extrem
hohe geschwindigkeiten trotz dieser
hohen beschleunigung wird ihre reise
zu unserem nachbar sonnensystem wohl
über 20 jahre dauern die sonden sind
dabei im gegensatz dazu extrem kleinen
test sondern wurden bereits in den
erdorbit gestartet und kreisen bereits
um die erde
es sind die kleinsten je in die
erdumlaufbahn geschickten satelliten sie
messen rund dreieinhalb mal dreieinhalb
zentimeter also mini mini mini 1000 mal
kleiner als die bisher kleinsten
satelliten die cube satz wie sie etwa
ein kilogramm wegen dieses breit zu
werden diese mit mikro raumsonden
genannt wegen dagegen nur 4 gramm
denkbar wäre auch dabei dass die mindens
mini sondern jeweils unterschiedliche
aufgaben haben einige könnten fotos
machen anderen daten aus der atmosphäre
sammeln und so weiter das größte teil an
diesen sonnen ist jeweils das
sonnensegel es muss extrem groß sein und
möglichst viel schub zu entwickeln bei
dem projekt würden ganz viele solcher
sonnen richtung einfach centauri fliegen
um dann in kurzen vorbeiflug daten zu
sammeln allerdings hätten sie nur eben
sehr kurz zeit denn der vorbeiflug wäre
bei der hohen geschwindigkeit sehr
schnell wieder vorbei genau wie bei der
mutmaßliche alien sondern sie flog mit
hoher geschwindigkeit an der erde vorbei
und entdeckt haben wir sie erst als sie
sich schon wieder entfernte die
wissenschaftler halten es für
wahrscheinlich dass genau so ein mini
satellit mit seinem riesigen sonnensegel
an uns vorbei geflogen ist denn das
objekt ist so beschaffen gewesen wie es
für diese sonden geplant ist ein
riesiges sonnensegel das superdünne ist
die studie kommt zu einer dicke von 0,3
bis 0,9 millimetern und ein natürliches
material dass diese eigenschaften hat
ist nicht bekannt und einfach
unvorstellbar wie soll die natur so
etwas bauen
es kommt nur eine intelligente spezies
in frage die quasi das breakthrough
starterprojekt schon vor einiger zeit in
die tat umgesetzt hat gebaut vor etwa
100 jahren und in 25 jahren bekommen die
aliens vielleicht die daten von uns und
dabei können es auch mehrere sonden
sagen wie beim break fu star shop
projekt und wir haben eben nur eine
entdeckt oder aber nur einer hat uns
erreicht die flugzeit habe ich jetzt mal
aus dem breakthrough star shop projekte
rechnen hierbei sollen die sonden etwa
20 prozent der lichtgeschwindigkeit
erreichen und das vier lichtjahre
entfernten doppelsternsystem alpha
centauri
bild des zentauren am südhimmel in rund
20 jahren erreichen obama kam aus dem 25
lichtjahre entfernten system wege also
ungefähr aus dieser richtung
man kann sich ganz genau sagen und dann
aber auch nicht genau aus diesem system
aus der richtung weil bei vega
da kennen haben wir bisher nur eine
staubscheibe gefunden und ein exoplanet
wird darin nur vermutet zudem ist das
system auch noch sehr jung um am ohr
wahrscheinlich kommt damit er aus der
nähe und ja aber wer weiß vielleicht ist
der planet dort doch gewohnt auf jeden
fall würde dann die reise zur erde etwa
100 jahre dauern und das rücksenden der
daten 25 jahre also der besuch von
aliens zumindest aufgrund dieser
untersuchungsergebnisse der steht noch
in den sternen im wahrsten sinne des
wortes jetzt müssen wir diese region auf
jeden fall genauer untersuchen wer weiß
was dort zu finden ist wenn er kein
video dazu verpassen wollt dann
abonniert am besten auch den englischen
kanal jetzt einfach drauf kriegen von
links und da gibt es auch die eine oder
andere video premiere glocke nicht
vergessen und darunter geht es weiter
mit mysteriös objekte deckten isa star
planet ziel stay tuned